[Musique]
être doté de pouvoirs magiques
j'en avais rêvé moi quand j'avais 10 ans
je voulais être magicien mais j'avais
aucun pouvoir magique
par contre sur antenne 2 et fr3 il y
avait des prestidigitateurs
je passe vous rappelez il y avait majax
garcimore ça c'est pour les plus de 50
ans et donc il nous faisait des tours de
magie et moi ça me provoquait 3 plaisir
le premier bas voire impossible quoi des
trucs bizarres
il faisait sortir des lapins de son
chapeau le deuxième plaisir c'était de
comprendre le truc comprendre comment
ils faisaient ça ça me plaisait beaucoup
ça et le troisième plaisir c'est par
refaire donner à mon avoir mon avis
remis à moi-même j'arrive à ce qui est
autour de moi ma famille en particulier
la possibilité de faire des tours de
magie
bonjour monsieur fait offert une belle
boîte de garcimore à l'époque avec plein
de tours de magie dedans puis je faisais
des petits spectacles de magie
je n'ai pas vraiment très doué alors bon
noël suivant j'ai eu une autre boîte
magique à zx81 rappelle des souvenirs ça
c'est le début d'un micro informatique
c'est un petit ordinateur avec un cadre
mémoire dessus puis un petit programme
de basiques qui permettait de faire des
logiciels et là tu fais faire à la
machine des tours de magie des petits
logiciels justement alors j'ai construit
un on va dire
un compagnon artificielle et ce
compagnon artificielle et jouer avec mon
frère et moi à la roulette aurait tiré
un numéro au hasard entre 0 et 30 6 non
ce n'est pas très intelligent mais bon
c'était comme ça que ça se passait puis
petit à petit je me suis dit peut-être
qu'à force de jouer à cette roulette
mais y avoir un billet et on avait
remarqué des numéros qui re des plus
souvent alors on s'est dit tiens je
remplace joe récupère tous les tirages
je les mets dans le logiciel
et puis la machine mavs a tiré peut-être
plus souvent les numéros un bout de 100
à 200 num tirage
la machine à gagner plus souvent que
nous alors là on était un peu vexé qui
jouent à la roulette c'est un peu
répétitif ça la machine et se lasse
jamais et donc on a décidé d'aller jouer
ailleurs
alors j'ai continué j'ai appris j'ai
appris à utiliser la machine j'ai appris
à programmer
j'ai fait les études j'ai d'autres j'ai
trouvé d'autres passionnés en
informatique
puis j'ai appris à faire du beau
logiciels ont fait le domaine du génie
logiciel
donc on apprend à analyser concevoir
mettre en oeuvre bref tout ça et j'avais
quand même des héros que je voulais
rencontrer dans ma vie or mes héros
c'est des héros qui n'existe pas
vraiment il ya professeur tournesol
voyez c'est celui qui l'ont un temps
celui qui est un peu dans la lune mais
surtout qui emmène les gens dans la
nuque et puis il ya docteur emmett et
met brawn
quelqu'un connait la docteure d'un
retour à le futur voyez alors lui
transportent les gens du passé au futur
ça ça ça me plaisait beaucoup
alors en france des docteurs des
professeurs il y en a dans la recherche
alors j'ai décidé de faire la recherche
et j'ai choisi une discipline
scientifique qui existe depuis plus de
60 ans qui s'appelle l'intelligence
artificielle rien que l'association des
deux mots c'est magique intelligence
artificielle mettre de l'intelligence
dans la machine alors ben j'ai fait mais
j'ai commencé ma thèse
j'ai ouvert le capot de la machine et
j'ai été voir ce qu'il y avait dedans or
qu'est-ce qu'il est dedans rien pas de
sentiments pas d'émotions même pas
l'étincelle d'un raisonnement vraiment
rien tu as un peu déçu par contre autour
de moi beaucoup beaucoup d'intelligence
humaine parce que pour coder laissant
une façon de faire de l'intelligence
artificielle parce que c'est un peu ça
c'est essayer d'imaginer
des actes cognitif humain ça c'est
facile de l'imaginer et surtout de les
reproduire avec la machine est là il
faut être très intelligent faire ça j'ai
fait une thèse avec jacques pitra
pionnier en intelligence artificielle
symbolique et qui m'a appris à
comprendre la notion de connaissance de
meta connaissance de règles de meta
règles et avec tous à 20 ont donné
l'illusion de l'intelligence je suis
devenu illusionniste de l'intelligence
dans les machines il n'y a aucune
intelligence dans la machine mais j'en
donne l illusion
alors j'ai appris j'ai appris le truc
est ce que je vous propose aujourd'hui
c'est de vous partager le truc comment
on met de l'intelligence dans une
machine en pour ceux qui veulent rester
dans l'émerveillement
je vous propose de bouger vos oreilles
et de ne pas écouter de trucs bon je
vais il ya beaucoup de curieux ça fait
bien ça alors le première la première
chose pour faire d'intelligence il faut
de l'humain il faut des humains très
intelligent capable de comprendre ce que
c'est des variables une des structures
de données être capable de travailler
avec les dates à utiliser des règles et
puis construire des algues au bord des
algues au jeu vous expliquer un peu
comment ça fonctionne donc là je vous
poser une question simple qu'est ce que
vous voyez sur cette photo je vous
laisse un petit peu de temps ça va tout
le monde a vu les défendre combien de
photos il a fallu pour un humain pour
apprendre à l'éléphant avis regedit une
à deux photos papus nous donner une à
deux photos à un enfant il apprend un
éléphant avis la machine
pas du tout et enfin lyonnais beaucoup
beaucoup plus de photos et à cette
question qu'est ce qu'on voit sur cette
photo
aucune machine au monde est capable d'y
répondre il faut lui faire des
propositions de réponses sur cette photo
est ce que tu vois une tirelire
une vache un éléphant une cuillère et la
machine va répondre c'est probablement
un éléphant c'est une machine
statistiques
enfin compte ce qui se trouve derrière
ces ragots de reconnaissance c'est ce
qu'on appelle un grave probabiliste là
on rentre un peu dans les maths mais
vous avez versé très simple agra froid
billy c'est quoi des milliers donne
eu des milliers dark avec des
probabilités des seuils ça permet de
transformer une photo en un concept et
ça marche assez bien le problème c'est
que ce graphe 3 bis avec des milliers de
noeuds au cun humain n'est capable de le
construire
donc on a une astuce l'astuce c'est de
faire programmer par un autre programme
pour construire le premier programme
donc on fait un algo d'apprentissage
pour construire à naples qu'au dehors
des codes de reconnaissance alors
comment ça fonctionne
je vais lui donner dix vingt cent mille
dix mille photos d'éléphants dix mille
photos de cuillères 18 photos de vaches
et et le système va être capable de
reconnaître parmi toutes ces photos là
où les éléphants le gris cuillère largué
vaches il va faire une distinction entre
les trois classes et là à partir de là
il est capable de reconnaître ce qu'on
veut il est capable de reconnaître dans
des photos dans des vidéos dans des
textes les cabas de rennes des
situations dans la rue par des caméras
vidéo ou même des comportements
on peut tout faire apprendre à la
machine à partir du moment qu'on a les
datas et qu'on a labellisé chaque data
le problème c'est que c'était aussi
simple
ben on serait on aurait beaucoup dia
partout et il faut un petit peu de temps
le problème c'est ça
l'éléphant rose alors là je vous demande
pas de regarder ça ressemble à un
éléphant ses héros ça n'existe pas et
pour la machine ben c'est un peu ambigu
parce que il ya beaucoup de tirs ni rose
qu'on lui a montré donc il dit c'est
peut-être une tirelire c'était un
éléphant et le rôle du développeur c'est
de supprimer ce type de feu de data on
ne met pas de date à hambye lui
justement pour que le système soit
performant mais ça veut dire aussi que
l'ia va voir beaucoup beaucoup de mal à
comprendre et analyser l'exception et ça
c'est un rôle du mince à gérer
l'exception pourquoi pas des gens n'a
pas beaucoup de 2
deux dates ajustements pour pouvoir
confluent faire apprendre des exceptions
alors mais un autre problème c'est que
les personnes qui sélectionne ses photos
qui font ce rôle là en général ils sont
américains chinois un petit peu européen
c'est des hommes entre 25 et 50 et 50
ans et ils sont ingénieurs
c'est un profil bien fermé et c'est eux
qui déterminent pour les ia du futur ben
ce qui est la vérité de ce qui est pas
la vérité ça ça pose un vrai problème
c'est à dire que la diversité de la
population mondiale n'est pas dans ceux
qui construisent les compagnons qui vont
nous accompagner tous les jours dans le
futur et si on veut une certaine égalité
par exemple hommes femmes
il va falloir que les femmes viennent
nous rejoindre pour les coder
l'intelligence artificielle si vous le
faites pas il faudra pascal qui a pas
d'égalité
je suis vraiment désolé de vous le dire
c'est urgent que vous venez nous
rejoindre et dit c'est pas très
compliqué hein
bref ce type de photos là aucune ni à
peu comprendre que c'est un éléphant un
enfant est capable d'identifier une
abstraction comme ça un humain non la
machine non alors entre parenthèses les
ja vous allez en avoir dans toutes vos
activités vous allez avoir déjà bon la
vie est longue gps il ya une ia qui
permet de vous guider vous avoir des
coachs sportifs des coachs pour vous
mais vous alimentez vous aurez des
coachs artificielle qui seront
disponibles 24 heures sur 24 vous avoir
des moteurs de recommandation vous en
avez déjà sur netflix par exemple qui
vous propose le film que vous avez
besoin de voir alors quand ça fonctionne
je vous explique en fait des profils ont
fait des profits de chacun de vous on
voit tous les films que vous avez aimé
et tous les filles vous avez arrêté au
milieu que vous avez été revoir un film
à côté c'est à dire qu'il vous plaît pas
et vous faites partie d'une classe comme
des millions sur cette planète qui
requiem ce type de film et qui déteste
cela et là naturellement la machine elle
voit un défi vous ai pas encore vus
tenez tiens je te propose ce film là il
ya de fortes chances que tu vas aimer
parce que tu fais partie des gens qui
peut aimer ce type de film c'est pareil
pour amazon et c'est pareil pour tous du
système de recommandations qu'on trouve
sur cette planète
on va pouvoir interagir avec cette
machine on va pouvoir
à log et avec elle et puis petit à petit
on voit aussi la possibilité pour les
machines de générer du texte générer des
images c'est plus vu sur internet assez
impressionnant ce qu'ils sont capables
de faire sont capables de faire revivre
la joconde par exemple c'est vraiment
une grande avancée alors quand on m'a
proposé ce rct dit que c'est très
content je suis allé le fait de lire
donc c'est parti je cherche un programme
qui permet de générer un télex bon ça
existe pas et ça existe dans la prod
raison simple c'est que chaque qui dit
que c'est un petit peu unique
c'est un peu comme l'éléphant rose de
tout à l'heure donc là il ya peu de
chances qu'on puisse générer de manière
automatique intellinx après une aussi
bon je vais utiliser un moteur de
recommandation qui permet de construire
le tedx toujours pas un un chat botté
qui j'aurais pu dialoguer rien non j'ai
utilisé pas utiliser les humains j'ai eu
des bouquins j'ai regardé les autres
tedx sur internet je regardais tous les
tout ce qu'on proposait comme come back
home contraintes et puis comme rôle
comme façon d'être
etc etc puis je me suis tourné vers les
humains des amateurs des professionnels
et puis des copains des amis or d'abord
je veux les remercier parce que j'étais
saoul et ses 2 derrière ces deux
derniers mois donc ça c'est important
mais tout ça c'est uniquement
d'intelligence humaine alors ce que je
vous propose aujourd'hui c'est
construire vos compagnons de demain mais
avant je vous en propose jean vous en
montrer un voilà alors je l'appelais
michel et depuis le début de la
présentation il récupère tous les maux
que j'aimais et il me effet en gros j'ai
beaucoup parlé de photos j'ai parlé d'
intelligence artificielle de vidéos de
tours de magie et naturellement il a
enregistré tous à michel il va
m'accompagner dans le futur je vais le
doter delà de la vision pour qu'ils
puissent mener des conseils par exemple
de sortir la main de la poche de bien me
positionner dans le cercle rouge etc etc
michel j'espère qu'il va me donner des
conseils du niveau par exemple la dame
que je vois pas où sont là bas puisque
michel voix et lui ont elles il ne sait
pas encore trop un
donc voilà dames la bac nos fonds qui
est en train de s'ennuyer avec son
téléphone portable
être à l'aller c'est une petite
information à l'entrée que elle
travaille pour l'ameublement par exemple
et là je veux lui donner une information
pour récupérer son attention les ia ne
sont pas capables de
on était des bugs litière certains
humains non plus et oui donc michel j'ai
vraiment envie qui qui m'accompagnent
dans toutes mes conférences est là
aujourd'hui je le présente sur c'est
juste ça c'est un petit proto mais je
vais vraiment l'améliorer au fur à
mesure
alors ce que je vous propose aujourd'hui
c'est que vous construisez vos propres
compagnons vous allez me dire alors
c'est pas possible il faut un super
niveau et c'est pas du tout donc j'étais
bonne boîte grenobloise il aurait
proposé de créer moi michel m'ont dit
comment on fait bah vous connaissez un
petit peu un peu l'informatique niveau
vaincu sochaux combien 2 3 et puis la
capacit mais par contre ce ne sont pas
des spécialistes de l'intelligence
artificielle
on a récupéré des programmes existants
sur le net
et puis on a commencé à construire cette
intelligence artificielle petit à petit
vous pouvez tous créer votre propre
intelligence artificielle oublier la
technique et commencez à vous dire
qu'est-ce que je sous traiterait
qu'est-ce que vous souhaiterez trier à
la machine la routine c'est pas vos
plannings peut-être la gestion du temps
les anniversaires qu'on oublie voyez ce
type de choses on pourrait sous traité à
la machine toute la partie très
répétitives préparer les repas au
quotidien
ça m'a fait penser un fake aulas enfin
quand ça va vous décharger de la vôtre
charge mentale
c'est surtout ça qui est important c'est
à dire que naturellement la deuxième
colonne qui est vous vous allez pouvoir
la compléter et pouvoir y rajouter des
tonnes d'activité vous n'aviez pas le
temps de faire avant la création
l'exploration le ressenti les envies la
passion et des tonnes de choses qui sont
on en a eu un exemple sur aujourd'hui
qui montrent que si on avait un petit
peu plus de temps et que la partie
ingrat de nos vies on sous traite à la
machine on serait plus heureux mais le
problème c'est que il faut pas attendre
que les laits on a vu aussi un ted
intéressante a été filmée faut pas
attendre que les légats falla
aujourd'hui définissent vos compagnons
de demain c'est à vous les construire et
vous pouvez le faire alors je suis pas
devenu un magicien ça c'est vrai j'ai
pas de vue un magicien j'ai construit
michel michel va pas me remplacer dap à
venir sur scène
faire un pitch et puis présenté
l'intelligence artificielle non il est
pas capable il sera encore très très
loin de faire ce type d'intelligence
artificielle
quand j loin c'est 50 cent ans on sait
même pas comment construire c'est pas
avec l'intelligence d'aujourd'hui tous
genres artificielle d'aujourd'hui qu'on
est capable de faire ce type
d'intelligence la voiture autonome 2035
pas avant il ya tellement de complexité
je parle d'une voiture qui serait
capable de se déplacer dans n'importe
quel environnement
pourquoi mais parce que aujourd'hui l'ia
ne permet pas de le faire
il va falloir inventer une nouvelle
intelligence artificielle et beaucoup de
limites là alors j'ai appris aussi bas à
donner l'illusion
ça c'est mon côté magicien je suis
plutôt content donc ça donne l'illusion
d'intelligence mais on a bien on est
bien d'accord ce n'est qu'une illusion
j'ai pris et j'ai appris aussi à
vulgariser être capable de parler de
choses complexes et laura et les ramener
à des concepts simples que tout le monde
peut comprendre et ainsi échelle
entreprises avec lesquelles je travaille
ça leur permet de prendre des décisions
mais pour faire tout ça
vulgariser construire etc j'ai utilisé à
vrais pouvoirs magiques
est ce vrai pouvoir magique vous l'avez
tous au fond de vous c'est
l'intelligence humaine et je vous prie
de bien le respecter
vous êtes tous des magiciens tous et
cher magicienne cher magicien je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]